oh yeah i definitely
i'm not a good cutter so don't zoom in
on me
i'm not professional whatsoever
that clip of kendall jenner cutting a
cucumber had fans totally shook and now
the 26 year old model is weighing in
calling the whole thing tragic just
gotta chop up some cucumber it's pretty
amazing i don't know i'm kind of scared
let's get you up to speed
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style you have a real
insight into what the girls are doing
well during the latest episode of hulu's
the kardashians fans got a real insight
into kenny's culinary skills or lack
thereof while making a midday snack do
you want um the chef to make you a snack
i'm making it myself just gotta chop up
some cucumber it's pretty amazing
you go girl
be careful because i cut i nicked myself
the other day i don't know i'm kind of
scared there you go don't cucumbers have
seeds
oh yeah they're definitely
not a good cutter so don't zoom in on me
i'm not professional whatsoever
hey chef
do you want to cut this up for her i'll
do it mommy's fine
yeah if you've ever chopped a cucumber
before you'll notice that kenny's hand
placement is pretty
unconventional and that haphazard veggie
cutting technique has since gone viral
with viewers tweeting their shock and
awe the model and reality star has gone
viral for a very bizarre culinary
blunder yep the moment was even
discussed on the today show friday
i've sliced many a cucumber in my day i
don't see
has a different style what was wrong
with that i don't know she was holding
it people were enraged the reality star
took notice of all the chatter and
helped online to respond calling her
kitchen skills quote tragic i'm not a
good cutter so don't zoom in on me
i'm not professional whatsoever and
while kendall admits she's not the best
at cutting veggies she is savvy at
knowing when to cut the cameras the cool
part about kylie and i growing up on the
show
and something that maybe we don't take
for granted is you know we got to see
things happen before we got you know
older our older sisters kind of
experienced a life that we got to view
and so just from a really young age i
think both kylie and i kind of knew what
we wanted to keep off the show or what
we wanted to keep to ourselves and
yeah i think that it's kind of as simple
as that and while kendall is careful
about what she shares on tv something
tells us she never could have imagined
her cucumber and hummus would have the
people talking
just gotta chop up some cucumber it's
pretty easy
you go girl
[Music]
you